hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in a
match between Magnus Carlsen and gukesh
and it's from the blitz section uh the
five plus one Blitz section because as
you know in the speeches Championship
they play uh three uh time controls they
play five plus one three plus one and
then one plus one so uh first uh an hour
and a half of uh five plus one then an
hour of three plus one and then half an
hour of bullet one plus one uh and this
is again from the uh five plus one
section uh I thought you you guys would
enjoy this one it's a very nice attack
and the the match Was Won by Magnus it
was a pretty crushing defeat 23-7 uh
although uh did much better in the end
than in in the beginning of the match uh
but this is one game I thought you guys
might enjoy so let's uh check it out
it's a game uh from the I don't know
what's before uh uh quarterfinals like
you have the finals the semi-finals the
quarterfinals and then whatever is
before that this is from that like the
eight finals or you know 16 people thing
I don't know the word for it but this is
from there so Magnus with the white
pieces opens with the D4 we have Knight
to F6 C for E6 Knight to F3 and now D5
we have the Queen's Gambit declined and
now Knight the C3 uh offering uh Lucas
to go for Bishop to B4 and he does it
Bishop to B4 Dora goes and defenses on
the board we have E3 and bookish castles
transposing into the nimso Indian and
now Ponte A3 Bishop to D3 is still by
far the most popular we have A3 Bishop
captures and C3 be captures and now D
captures on C4 this is extremely rare
usually you will see something like C5
or or Knight to C6 but the captures on
C4 in this particular position is very
rare
and Magnus recaptures Bishop captures in
C4 C5 by gokish and now Magnus castles
and here there are some known moves like
C characters and D4 Knight b37 Queen to
C7 all known moves but B6 is a new move
so now already as of move 9 we have a
completely new game and Magnus goes for
Queen to E2 he develops the queen now he
has to develop the bishop to connect the
Rooks uh and queen to C7 and this is
already slightly uh in uh well incorrect
Bishop to B7 has to be played here in
order to prevent Magnus from advancing
his spawn to E4 or you could put a
knight to the E4 this is all I mean
Bishop to B7 Fall by Knight T4 those are
the moves you want to play uh Lucas goes
for Queen the C7 and this uh will create
problems for him as Magnus pushes E4
right away uh which would not be
possible uh now comes Knight B to D7 and
pawn to E5 chases away the Knight and
now this diagonal opens up and you can
never have a knight on F6 uh pretty much
for the rest of the game with Knight to
D5 Knight to G5 now out of nowhere an
attack
um emerges and now Magnus is playing
some Queen D3 Queen C2 action to go
after the H7 Pawn so H6 kicking the
Knight away from their Knight to E4 and
now again it's a very very uh difficult
to play this with black
uh Bishop to B7 should have been played
and it should be played now with Bishop
to B7 maybe black still has some hopes
of defending this position but gookish
plays Pawn to F6 and now the position is
completely winning for Magnus I will
allow you guys to to pause the video and
and try to figure out how it's a very
nice idea so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Magnus while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh completely
busting open the black King's position
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show yeah it is of course
Bishop captures on H6 and now there
really isn't a good continuation
uh you could say okay I'm not gonna
capture on H6 I'm gonna play something
like Bishop to B7 but then Magnus would
just continue happily uh offering
offering the bishop and now you kind of
have to capture it and now let's say
queen to G4 King to F7 and now Knight to
D6 check and now a nice King Khan begins
Queen to G7 King to d8 and now Pawn to
F4 and if you can survive this then I
mean you're you're a spectacular player
but this is objectively completely
winning for white I will just show you a
fun line for example Bishop to C6 the
prepare B5 uh F5 is coming and if e
captures just Knight captures and now if
Pawn to B5 you're gonna trade here
Bishop captures Bishop captures and
Ponte E6 and there is nothing for you to
do here you can't move the Knight
because the Rook hangs you can't um uh
well you can't really do nothing because
then E7 check will win the Rook uh
either way and if Bishop captures then
just Queen to E7 check and you win back
the piece King C8 Queen captures and 6
and you won back your PC or up material
and um well the there's just no no way
to play this with black uh you still
have to get the Rook into the game but
also the King has no defense
so instead after Bishop captures on H6 G
captures on H6 was played and now you of
course know what magnus's idea is he
wants to bring the Rook into the game
via a nice Rook one to D3 Rook lift and
then try and Checkmate the black king So
Queen to G4 with check first and now
King the h8 here King to F7 liking the
line that we've shown uh doesn't really
work here it's even worse after Anita D6
check King E7 Queen G7 checking to d8
you can even play this right away Bishop
capture C captures are now just Knights
to F7 with check and that's pretty much
it Rook captures Queen captures and
whatever you play let's say have
captures an E5 just Queen to G8 check
King G8 and the D captures an E5 leaving
black without
um all that many options you can't
develop the bishop because the Rook
would hang okay you can play Bishop to
B7 but then we just move the queen with
the check and basically Rook is coming
T1 you will have a rook on F1 F4 F5 F6
E6 and that's it there's no playing this
so after Queen to G4 checkbook cash
tries King the h8 but now Queen to G6
now Magnus goes for the H6 spawn and if
you capture or Advance then there's even
characters and H6 with checking to G8
Queen captures and E6 with check and
then uh the entire position falls apart
so Bishop to B7 finally gookish plays
this move but now Queen captures an H6
king j8 queen to G6 with checking to h8
and now Rook 8 D1 coming in for a nice
Rook to D3 Rook to H3 Checkmate so
Knight captures an E5 Lucas gives back a
material to try and defend this D
captures Queen captures on E5 and now
uh Magnus should play something like
either Queen to H6 to get the Queen off
of the off of the G file because it
could matter or just continue with Rook
to D3 I will show you because it's a
fine it's it's a fun line and Knight to
F4 now that's uh the reason why Magnus
did not go for this probably as it's a
Blitz game so you know he just wanted to
get rid of that Knight because it
attacks the Queen the rook and guards
the H3 square but still Queen H6 check
King to G8 now look at this Rook the G3
checking to F7 king queen to H7 checking
gate and now there's this bishop to B5
check and that's it there's no playing
this King 38 Queen D7 will be Checkmate
however after Queen captures an E5 uh
Magnus played Bishop captures on D5 he
just didn't want to allow that Knight to
F4 move I imagine and now he captures on
D5 which allows Magnus to just win on
the spot but with Bishop captures on D5
it would be a bit trickier
uh because now if you if you continue
with Rook to D3 there's the incredible
Queen F5 and now if Rook the H3 with
check you play Queen captures on H3 and
now if G captures a rook the Jade wins
back the White Queen and now it's black
who's winning the problem is even after
Bishop captures on D5 Magnus doesn't
have to play Rook to D3 He can play
pretty much anything and he will still
be winning like Rook uh rook fp1 and
okay white is still winning uh but it
would be uh you know it would require a
bit more works but uh Luke has played e
captures and E5 and now Rook to D3 by
Magnus with uh uh and after Rook to D3 I
was in this position on move 23 that
bookish resigned in the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is if you if you capture for example an
E4 then Rook to H3 check you have to
block with the queen and this will now
be Checkmate and even if you don't if
you try something like a best of the C8
the guard the dh3 square so Rook H3 is
not possible Rook G3 and now you cannot
defend against Rook the G7 Checkmate
okay you could play Rook def 7 but then
this is Checkmate because the Rook uh
the Rooks are now disconnected as the
bishop was placed on C8 so yeah there is
nothing you can do here after Rook to D3
bookish resigned and another great
Victory it was for Magnus Carlsen in the
five plus one uh Blitz section uh so
yeah like I said the final result was 27
to 23 to seven so here gookish did get
some wins and he even got some nice
checkmates but it was a pretty much of a
just a crushing victory for uh for
Magnus Carlsen who will now face uh
Fabiano caruana in the quarterfinals of
the speed Chess Championship uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and learned how to attack the nimsu
Indian defense maybe when it's played
with not not the the most precise move
order I also hope you enjoyed that as
well I would like to thank Zoltan
koscardi yeah Benjamin halberger uh
ravishing reptiles YouTube home and
anubav katiel for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it it as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and basically whatever else
happens in the Chess World most likely
also including the speed Chess
Championship and whatever happens there
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day